[Music]
we have first to consider the simple
unitary substance itself in the
immediate organization of its moments
which are present in the substance but
as yet have not been stirred into life
in the same way that nature displays
itself in the universal elements of air
water fire and earth here is the
enduring purely universal and
transparent element water the element
that is perpetually sacrificed fire the
unity which energizes them into
opposition while at the same time yet
perpetually resolves the opposition
lastly earth which is the firm and solid
knot of this articulated whole the
subject of these elements and of their
process that from which they start into
which they return so in the same way the
inner essence or simple spirit of self
conscious actuality displays itself in
similar such Universal but here
spiritual masses or spheres displays
itself as a world in the first sphere it
is an implicitly universal self
identical spiritual being in the second
it is explicitly for itself it has
become inwardly divided against itself
sacrificing and abandoning itself in the
third which has soft consciousness is
subject it possesses it directly in its
own self the force of fire in the first
in his conscious of itself as an
intrinsic being but in the second it
develops an explicit being of its own by
sacrificing the universal spirit however
is itself at once the essence and the
actuality of the whole which sunders
itself into a substance which endures
and a substance which sacrifices itself
and which at the same time also takes
them back into its unity it is both the
outburst of flaming fire which consumes
the substance and also the abiding form
of that substance we see that these
spheres correspond to the community and
the family and the ethical world without
however possessing the native spirit
peculiar to the ladder on the other hand
while destiny is alien to the spirit
here self-consciousness is and knows
itself to be the real power of these
spheres
in paragraph 482 Hegel is drawing an
analogy between what he calls the
elements of nature and what is going on
with substance and and spirit in this
culture section and I think that it's a
bit difficult for us to grasp it with
the same force of conception than that
he intended for the audience of his time
which you know if they were literate
they they they knew that nature was not
really you know earth air fire water the
way the ancients and and the medievals
and even some of the early modern had
thought but they weren't quite as far
away from that as as we are now so it's
important I think in this in this
passage not to see Hegel is doing
something like you know appealing to
alchemy or anything along those lines
but to look very closely at what it is
that he's saying about these elements
and what their parallels would then be
in spirit so he says we have to first
consider the simple unitary substance
itself in the immediate organization of
its moments which are present in the
substance but as yet have not been
stirred into life and now notice by the
very end of this he's going to be
talking about some ground that we've
already tread some familiar ground
talking about destiny talking about the
ethical world the community the family
all those sorts of things though it's
not as if he hasn't already gone over
this a bit now we're moving into a
different section where the
differentiation is going to take place
through other values through through
other instantiation of what what the
substance in this case understood in
terms of human culture is going to be so
why is Hegel bringing up stuff like
earth air fire and water well we have to
look at what what those actually do so
he says in the same way nature displays
itself in the universal elements of
air water fire and earth what are these
elements doing I mean if you look at the
older theories about this you had you
know for example ear is dry and and and
light and you know won't warm or you
know things like that you know these
different cosmic forces right fire is is
dry and and and and hot so air must be a
dry and cold and these you know worked
in with each other and there were these
sort of complex theories about what
water bones made of earth plus the
certain amount of this and a certain
amout of that Hegel's not interested in
any of that
what is he interested in here I mean it
tells you right here in the text each of
these represents a certain kind of force
a certain kind of way for substance to
be in terms of nature so it says air is
the enduring purely universal and
transparent element what does that mean
air is everywhere
air doesn't do an awful lot in terms of
the way in which Hegel is
conceptualizing the process I mean we
know of course that air does a lot of
things meteorologically for ourselves
and higgles not worried about that then
we have water now notice what he says
about water water is the perpetually
sacrificing element and yet it doesn't
go away does it so the sacrifice is not
a complete sacrifice of its being he
says water is the element that is
perpetually sacrificed then fire the
unity which energizes them into
opposition while at the same time it
perpetually resolves the opposition now
if you think about fire that we have
today we think about fire primarily
consuming things and as a matter of fact
I mean it's really this is a bit of a
side note but if you think about the
evolution of the planet not only in
terms of
evolution of life but but also
meteorological and even what we might
call you know potentialities for
chemical phenomenon apparently from what
you know of the scientists think it
wasn't even possible to have fire as
such through a good portion of Earth's
history certainly hot things but we had
to have enough oxygen in the air for
that kind of oxidation to be taking
place that actually required a change of
of things through life now what is Hegel
talking about here in terms of fire this
is very similar to how say the Stoics
conceived of fire or the way other
people who are using fire is kind of a
stand-in for other other elements
Heraclitus in this case two fire is the
logos the the reason that runs through
things or the word if you like he talked
about fire as putting things into their
opposition right so fire is the
dialectical element isn't it and then
resolving those opposition's
so we've got three elements here then he
says something that's really kind of
mind-blowing about earth earth he says
here we go is the firm and solid what
firm and solid fundament no he doesn't
say that the firm and solid not the
tying together of this articulated whole
what does the articulated whole the
whole of all the elements so there's a
kind of self reflectiveness in earth as
well as in in fire which presumably is
you know not just opposing other things
to each other but also to itself and in
water but earth is tying them all
together there's another place later on
where Hegel is going to use this this
term not and that's in the religion
section when he talks about religion as
binding together all of the previous
dialectical
in consciousness self-consciousness
reason spirit so this is a very strange
kind of natural typology of the elements
isn't it
what is Hegel after here well he tells
us he says in the same way the inner
essence or simple spirit or self
conscious actuality displays itself in
such universal but now here spiritual
masses or spheres it we saw this before
with ethical substance right breaking
itself up into spiritual masses we saw
this in terms of it as doing so through
laws we saw it doing this in terms of
the family and the state you know the
community now we're seeing it in terms
of other developments that are more
directly tied with with culture and this
the Galleon movement of you know
beginning from certainty trying to move
to truth losing certainty in the process
coming back and trying to have truth and
certainty together or another way of
looking at this original you know
immediacy alienation alienation of
alienation coming back but no longer
coming back to exactly the same place
but a sublated higher level of the
original position so he says what are
these spheres like in the first sphere
it is an implicitly universal self
identical spiritual being sort of like
air right and in this discussion so a
self identical spiritual being something
that exists in it and when Hagel calls
immediacy right something you can take
for granted
he says in the second it is explicitly
for itself and has become divided
against itself by being for itself by
having that distance between its in
itself and its awareness of its in
itself it can now have differentiation
within itself and be divided against
itself this is what it is to have
culture to develop culture to
enculturate oneself to form oneself to
different ways in which we could
translate bill then ZigBee than you know
working upon oneself as opposed to build
donor the process or the product of that
that inculturation what's the third
thing he tells us that the third here is
he says his self-consciousness as
subject and here he says it possesses
directly in its own self the force of
fire what does that mean it has the
force of fire the kind of fire that
Hagel was talking about here of taking
the opposition's and reconciling them
integrating them recuperating them
making them into something that one can
be so he goes on and he you know sums us
up he says in the first it's conscious
of itself as an intrinsic being as a
being in itself right but in the second
it develops an explicit being of its own
by sacrificing the universal spirit by
saying I am myself I am for myself it
Strange's itself from the universal
spirit in the third it is coming back
together with it but no longer just
going back to in intrinsic or in itself
being right he says there we go spirit
is itself at once the essence and
actuality of the whole which sunders
itself into a substance which endures
and a substance which sacrifices itself
both of these are still in play at the
same time both of these are the self and
he says at the same time also takes them
back into its unity so we have a greater
unity here it's in a certain way we
could say you know if you feel alienated
that's not always bad that's not always
something to be overcome I mean if it is
overcome its overcome through this
integrative process not by
going back to the start and saying I'm
gonna put my head in the sand and
pretend that my whole history never
happened to me or that I didn't learn
anything in the process or that I didn't
change myself through the formation of
my capacities through culture so he goes
on and he says it is at both the
outburst of flaming fire which consumes
the substance and also the abiding form
of that substance so here's the question
that we should ask them what is counting
as the fourth thing here earth right
we've got air stuff identical self in
itself right we've got water in orderly
divided against itself self-sacrificing
all that sort of stuff we have fire this
you know cool process reminiscent to the
Herrick Lydian or stoic logos wonderful
stuff then we've got earth this this
knot that ties them all together
what's corresponding to that down here
there isn't a complete correspondence in
this passage that should raise some some
questions for you
the closest Hegel is getting to this is
in that that part where he's saying it's
both the outbursts of flaming fire but
also the abiding form of that substance
that's the closest thing that he's
getting to the earth as solid not here
then he starts talking about previous
things we've gone through we see that
these spheres correspond to the
community and the family in the ethical
world without however possessing the
native spirit peculiar to the latter
what is that the ethical world right
thinks is on the other hand well destiny
is alien to the spirit here
self-consciousness is and knows it's
tough to be the real power these spheres
in the previous section Destiny showed
up as something alien something foreign
here the the alienists and foreignness
is within the individual self
consciousness developing through culture
we have to consider how in the first
instance these two members are
represented within pure consciousness as
thoughts or as having only an implicit
being and also how they are represented
in actual consciousness is having an
objective existence in the simple form
of thoughts the first is the good the
self accordant immediate and
unchangeable essence of every
consciousness the independent spiritual
power of the in itself alongside which
the activity of actual consciousness is
something merely incidental its other on
the contrary is the passive spiritual
essence or the universal insofar as it
surrenders itself and allows individuals
to get in at the consciousness other
separate existence it is the essence
that is null and invalid the bad is the
absolute breakup of the essence is
itself permanent well the first essence
is the foundation starting point and
result of individuals who in it are
purely universal the second time the
other Yin is partly their
self-sacrificing being for another and
partly for that very reason their
perpetual return to itself as separate
individuals and the perpetual process in
which they develop a being of their own
after his analogy between culture and
spirit on the one hand and nature and
its elements on the other in the
previous paragraph here in paragraph 493
we're going to see Hegel grappling with
a somewhat different aspect of this
how does spirit actually articulate
itself particularly in terms of these
values of good and bad and this is a
very important turning point because
it's going to lead us into questions
having to do with determinate goodness
and badness and we're gonna see this is
just projecting a little bit ahead how
this this interplay between these
opposites which Hegel is characterized
earlier as being in an absolute
opposition or antithesis and Gagan stand
to each other just two paragraphs
earlier how these take on determinate
content and flip from from one polarity
to the other how you know how something
can become good as opposed to something
else that's bad and how does this happen
in the historical process you might say
what he's doing here if we wanted to be
a little bit you know cheeky is akin to
what Nietzsche later on called a
genealogy of morals tracing out how
these various values wind up becoming
instantiated and made actual veer Creek
in in reality in history in culture here
what is he talking about he says we now
have to consider how these two members
are represented within pure
consciousness as thoughts whereas having
only an implicit being as being on Zeke
right and also how they are represented
in actual consciousness is having an
objective existence so what we have here
is a kind
tenshun we've got more than one
consciousness or type of consciousness
going on and trying to grasp this this
polarity this opposition between good
and bad and so what we have to do in in
thinking this is go from a good versus
bad where they're essentially both on
the same level in this absolute
antithesis of thought that we saw
several paragraphs ago to something
where we have the good as that which is
higher the bad that which is lower we're
not yet at the point where like this
would be universal
versus individual as a matter of fact
the individual can fit into either of
these and we'll see how that happens in
the rest of this this paragraph so what
does Hegel say next he says in the
simple form of thoughts the first is the
good the good right this is a cognate
they're right same word basically now
what does he do to characterize the good
the self accordant immediate
unchangeable essence of every
consciousness you know if we've been
traversing this path of the
phenomenology not only should we be
thinking here okay that's pure
consciousness or the transcendental ego
or you know human nature writ large or
however we want to put it the you the
general will if we live if you like the
Rousseau Yin language but this is this
talk about the unchangeable immediate
self accordant harmonious essence
doesn't this recall all the talk about
what we were seeking in the unhappy
consciousness section where the good was
projected as the eternal the unchanging
and and we we left ourselves behind as
dregs that we experienced scum
essentially in relation to that good god
or divine or
whatever it is over that there were
yearning to try to connect back up with
there should be some residents of that
here that's the good right the first is
the good the self according to immediate
and unchangeable essence of every
consciousness here he says the
independent spiritual power of the in
itself alongside of which the activity
of actual consciousness is something
merely incidental it is the universal as
that to which the individual must
sacrifice him or herself the Hegel
doesn't talk here about culture does he
this by the way should also remind us of
another section that we traversed
earlier in the reason portion of the
work virtue and the way of the world as
well right what was virtue it was to
sacrifice herself for the universal for
the good to take what what we have is
individuality and subordinated this also
happened by the way in the discussion of
the ethical substance just in this
earlier portion of spirit that we're now
finished with when the individuals
really line themselves up with the
ethical they subordinated themselves now
it's a process of culture of development
of subordinating oneself in practical
activities that are forming who one is
and the more that one does that the more
that one lines one's self up with the
good in this way in a certain sense the
less one is an individual right there's
maybe something gained by it the feeling
of being the universal but maybe there's
something lost what about the bad notice
what he has to say about the bad here so
he says it's other the contrary is the
pass of spiritual essence or the
universal insofar as it surrenders
itself and allows individuals to get in
at the consciousness of their separate
existence it is the essence that is null
and invalid the bad what makes it bad in
some sense you get the idea here it's
precisely because it's too permissive
it's not the bad
in the sense of you know being
overpowering and tyrannical or something
like that instead it's not tyrannical
enough the way the good is this is a
very interesting conception isn't it and
this is the schlecht right notice that
Hegel does not say the Boozer the evil
here at this point but rather the
Schleck that which is in a certain sense
deficient it falls short of the good
it's not as if it has any goodness it's
not as good as the good right and what
it does is it allows it sacrifices
itself he's as passive spiritual essence
its self-sacrificing it makes too much
room for the individual to find him or
herself in it as individual as actual
consciousness not just as subordinated
to the universal as being a good boy or
good girl
but being a an actual boy actual girl
with desires with with a history with
screw-ups on their record and thoughts
about what that means well this is a
very interesting conception of good and
bad isn't it so he goes on and he says
this absolute break up of the essence is
itself permanent while the first essence
is the foundation starting point and
result of individuals who in it are
purely universal the second on the other
hand is partly their self-sacrificing
being for another so notice what we have
opposed here is not the in itself to the
for itself but the in itself to the for
another on the part of the universal
this is what allows the individual to
become for itself right there's room in
the bad for the individual to become for
itself there isn't enough room here at
this point and good for the individual
to become for itself now this is rather
fascinating isn't it this is not Hegel's
final word on goodness and badness of
course but this is an important stage
isn't it you see how much this stands
out so he goes on and he says
partly for this very reason their
perpetual return to self as separate
individuals and the perpetual process in
which they develop a being of their own
so the question that we have to ask
ourselves not only how does spirit
articulate itself into the good and the
bad in this case these these fundamental
moral categories but where is the space
for the individual to fully develop
it's a ambiguous point isn't it because
the individuals can develop within the
band but can they fully develop into
what they need to be or does that
require going to the good but does the
good have the room for the individuals
to develop into what they need to be
maybe both are an impasse but the
individual cannot operate in a vacuum
these are the options now how is this
going to play itself out we're going to
get very concrete with this in the
paragraphs coming up
you